I'm Inspector Kildare of Scotland Yard.
I'm investigating a series of deaths.
They're calling them the Limehouse Golem murders.
At Ratcliff highway, he slaughtered a household.
The previous week, a prostitute.
The Golem is a madman.
Even madness has its own logic.
Inspector Kildare, I may have found an eyewitness in Limehouse, Sir.
I can't tell you what I know.
Just assist me, I promise I won't let anything happen to you.
Who was here on September 24th?
There were four men that day:...
...John Cree, Dan Leno, George Gissing, Karl Marx.
The newspaper said it was your first murder case.
The Yard is setting me up as a scapegoat.
The public want blood.
The Golem provides it.
He who observes spills no less blood than he who inflicts the blow.
It's a message...
...to us.